Speaker 1: Could the coming 2022 midterm election
be the worst midterm ever for Republicans?
In this particular situation, the situation being
one that should be very good for the Republican
Party if you look historically. I know many of you
are sick of hearing this from me, but I want to
remind everybody. Normally, when one party takes
the White House from the other party in the first
midterm election, after that, that very party then
loses a bunch of seats or potentially control of
the House or Senate. Meaning because Democrats
took the White House from Republicans in 2020,
2022 should be very, very good for Republicans.
And it was looking that way for a very long
time. And all of a sudden in the last month
and in particular in the last two weeks,
things are looking dramatically different. We
mentioned yesterday the Senate has approved this
Inflation Reduction Act bill to fight climate
change and cut drug costs. This is a major
accomplishment. Assuming that the House passes
it on Friday and then it is signed by Joe Biden,
both of which are expected to happen.
This is a massive Biden accomplishment.
And then when you look bigger picture at the
Biden accomplishments, you see that he did the
COVID stimulus, he did the Infrastructure and
Jobs Act. He confirmed the first black female
Supreme Court justice. He did some gun safety
legislation, although I think it's pretty weak
sauce. But at least it was something he did.
The Chips Act for semiconductor manufacturing,
the NAITO expansion to include Finland and Sweden
is in process. He expanded veterans health care.
He authorized the strike that killed terrorist
Ayman al-Zawahiri, which, believe me, I understand
there are legal questions about whether the
United States can or should be doing that,
but it is an accomplishment that Biden can
claim. Fantastic jobs report last week,
3.5% unemployment, 55 straight days of gas price
reduction, which again, remember, I don't even
think it has anything to do with Biden. I don't
think the upswing had anything to do with Biden.
I don't think the downswing has anything to do
with Joe Biden either. But the point is what is
reported and what can you take credit for? And
tomorrow we have an inflation number coming out,
which I expect to be significantly lower than
the peak numbers we saw over the last few months.
I may be wrong, but that's what I expect. And
if that's the case, it will be another indicator
that the economy is looking better and
better overall. Could this be a disastrous
midterm for Republicans? Well, the polling
data is increasingly pointing that way. After
looking for months and months like Republicans
were going to take the Senate definitively
from Democrats in the fall. The FiveThirtyEight
forecast for the Senate now has Democrats at 59%,
likely to retain control of the Senate. Now,
that's not overwhelming, but it is looking
increasingly good for Democrats in terms of the
Senate. Now, in the House, it's not looking very
good. It still looks like about an 80% chance that
Republicans win. Remember, 80% is not 100%. But
that's the way that it is looking right now. This
is a massive, massive reversal from the way things
looked and quite frankly, the way things should
look, speaking historically for Republicans.
What do you think we're going to see in
November? And then the last piece of this, as
we spoke about this a little bit with political
scientist Rachel Bitter Copper last week. She has
a slightly different view on it than I do. And I
know many of you have different views about this
because of the overturning of Roe v Wade. This
actually does seem like it is a midterm election
where running on abortion rights, on women
having autonomy over their medical decisions
could be very good for Democrats. Typically, it
is not an issue that is so good for Democrats.
Extraordinary circumstances. And as I've said
before, there are some elections which just don't
feel like they're that important. The 2022 midterm
and the 2024 presidential election, which are
honestly one in the same. I mean, the 24 election
is almost getting going right now. And we're going
to look at some of those numbers later as well,
because what is happening with Trump and de Santos
is extraordinary. Could this be a disaster
for Republicans? Let me know what you think